لمزيد من التفاصيل على الارض ينضم الينا
مباشره من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في
جده مراسل العربيه هاني صفيان حيث للتنويه
مشاهدينا وصلات سفينه جلاله الملك الرياض
قبل قليل وعلامتها دفعه جديده من النازحين
من السودان هاني الصوره معك من هناك لو
سمحت
نعم اهلا بك مجددا واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه ايضا على ظهر سفينه جلاله الملك
الرياض العربيه تواكب وصول رعايه القادمين
من السودان هذه السفينه التي تحمل على
متنها اكثر من 200 شخص وصلت للتو الى
قائده الملك فيصل البحريه وهي وقفت بالفعل
بشكل تام وها هي هذه اللحظات الان في
انتظار النزول الرعايه لكن هناك بروتوكول
بحري معروف لدى القوات اي او اي قوه بحريه
هي بصعود قائد الاسطول ويحيي الطاقم
الملاحي للسفينه ويحييهم ايضا لوصوله او
سلامه وصولهم وعلى الانجاز الذي حققوا اذا
ايضا ننقل الصوره من الجهه الاخرى وهي
سوره وصول الرعايه الذين وصلوا من جنسيات
مختلفه اسيويه وكذلك افريقيه وايضا بعض
الجنسيات الاوروبيه التي وصلت على هذه
اللحظات وهم قادمين بومبورت سودان
وهي سفينه قد غادرت ليله امس ووصلت في هذه
اللحظات طبعا هذه السفينه هي احدى سفن
التابعه للقوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه
وكانت لها مهمات عديده حقيقه سبق وان قامت
باجلاء العديد من او نفذت عمليات اجلاء
سابقه سواء في عرض البحر الاحمر او كذلك
في بعض الدول التي كانت تقوم لها او
تساندها في مهام سواء في افريقيا او كذلك
في اسيا ما زلنا ايضا نقوم بالتجول ونشاهد
ايضا الاعداد التي وصلت هي تقف الان في
انتظار لحظه فقط انهاء بعض الاجراءات على
الارض حتى يتمكنون من النزول بشكل
متتاليه ولكن ناخذ لقاء مع احد
اذا احد رايه القادمين من باكستان هو قدم
لمع هذه علامات هذه السفينه وهو ايضا
برفقه عائله الكمان نشاهد واحد الطاقم
السفينه يقوم باعطاء طفله
لحلوى وايضا هنا نشاهد احداث
الجنسيات العربيه
محمد عصام محمد من فلسطين الحمد لله على
سلامتك اولا دعنا نتحدث في جزئيه
الذين سبقوكم قالوا هناك ازدحام كبير في
بورسودان بسبب هناك من يحاول الوصول الى
بر الامان نتحدث عن الوضع هناك ما الذي
شاهدته وكم امضيت انت حتى توصل بورس
السودان او كذلك تقوم
بالصعود الى هذه السفينه او محاولتك لسفن
اخرى يعني والله قعدنا في الباص في الجزء
14 ساعه من الخرطوم لبورسودان بعدين قعدنا
هناك يومين في بورسودان تقريبا عشان في
ازدحام كبير من سواء سودانيين او
فلسطينيين او جنسيات ثانيه بس الحمد لله
لقينا في تعاون كبير من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اجلاء كان اول باول بس كان
الاداه كبيره طبعا يعني انت تحدث هناك
تعاون للسعوديه تحديدا ماذا عن يعني
السفارات الاخرى يعني حديثني بشكل اكثر
والله اغلب السفرات كانت التعاون مع السفر
مع الدوله السعوديه يعني
السفارات الثانيه كانت تستعين بالدوله
السعوديه تمام اعتقد ان الدوله السعوديه
كانت الطريق الوحيد تقريبا لاجلاء
الجاليات من من السودان لبر للسودان خلال
مشاهداتك يعني كم الاعداد التي كنتم
تشاهدونها هل هناك مازال المزيد كل يوم
كنا نشوف مثلا اعداد جديده كل يوم تقريبا
الف او اكثر كنا نشوف ويروحوا ويتجددوا
الف واكتر يعني يوميا ما يقارب الالف
طيب برج سودان وين كنت تسكن وين كنتمكر
والله في نفس نفس المكان لانه كنا نفكر
انه اول باول بس عشان تفاجانا بالاعداد
الكبيره المكان هذا وين بالضبط اللي هو
ماذا يسمى
البحريه او قاعده
تنسيق انه يتم الاجلاء او باول
كيف تم اختيارك هل هي بالارقام بالدور كيف
كان والله حسب قلت لك حسب تنسيق السفاره
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
السفاره الفلسطينيه مع المملكه العربيه
طيب بالنسبه لك كيف كان الوضع حدثني من اي
او اي مدينه كنت قادم
والله الخرطوم الوضع فيها صعب
صعب انه حاليا فيهم في عندهم تفريغ للمواد
الغذائيه في نقص السعاده في نقص الخدمات
الطبيه اكيد متابعه الاحداث اللي بتصير
صعب جدا للمستشفيات غير مهيئه للتحمل
الضغط الحالي
موضوع انه تدخل محلات ما تلاقي المواد
الغذائيه الاساسيه قطع الكهرباء والماء
هذه كان في مشاكل حقيقيه موجوده في
السودان في مناطق صعب الحركه فيها اصلا
فيها يعني قطع طرق والامور هاي السرقات هل
كنت تشاهد قطاع الطرق او كان يقال لك لا
لا انا شهرتهم قريبين منك كانوا يعني في
كل مكان شفنا ناس يسرق منهم حتى الطعام في
الشارع يعني الوضع كان صعب جدا عسكريه
غير عسكريين مدني عادي يعني بس يكون معه
اسلحه بيضاء يعني يكونوا يهجموا على الناس
ياخذوا منهم هاي الامور هل تعرضها تعرضت
او لمن تعرفه لهذه الحمد لله في يعني
اصدقاء اصدقاء من السودان يعني حاولوا
يامنونا لحد ما وصلنا السفاره وخرجنا من
الخرطوم
وفي حقيقه الامر الاعيان يعني كل ما اخذنا
لقاء مع احد الرعايه كنا يعني نسمع
بحكايات وقصص يعني جديده وليست ما كنا
نتوقعها يعني انت الان كنت تتحدث ان هناك
عمليات
بنهب عبر الاسلحه البيضاء
مش فقط نهب محلات سيارات احيانا المناطق
البنزين محطات البنزين والبترول بحرقوها
بسرقوها فيعني الموضوع خارج السيطره تماما
اصلا شارع خارج السيطره تماما
ايضا من اين اي منطقه فلسطين من الخرطوم
نعم لماذا تم اختيارك تحديدا لن تصعد على
هذه السفينه ما في حاجه يعني هو السفاره
فلسطينيه اعلنت انه راح نجلي كل الطلاب
تبعينها
في جامعه الرازي السنه الرابعه
فانه السفاره الفلسطينيه فتحت ابوابها على
طول ما قصرت معنا ابدا يعني حتى اي قالوا
اي ناس دارهم كانت في مهدده بالخطر انا
ذلك تمدد بالخطر القصر كان جمله تقريبا
جدا يعني وانقطعنا من الكهرباء والمي
والاكل وكل شيء فسفار الفاصوليا ما قصرت
معنا ابدا على طول تواصلت معنا وعلى طول
فتحت ابواب السفاره
وامنتن الطرق وكانت معانا اول باول خطوه
بخطوه وتواصلت مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه يعني الحمد لله كل شيء كان مسهل
يعني وبوفرونا الطريق والامن وكل اشي
والكهرباء والاكل وكل شيء يعني طيب هل
مازال هناك اعداد كبيره من الطلبه
الفلسطينيين او من ايضا
اخوانكم من الفلسطيني من الفلسطين تقريبا
نقدر نحكي تم اخراج 90% اذا
يقوم المصور بالتقاط هذه الصور استعدادا
لنزولهم طبعا هناك الاعداد كثيره وايضا
كبيره كما يشاهدون من النساء والرجال
وكذلك الاطفال نعم ليال تفضلي على كل حال
هاني فورا نزول هؤلاء وخروجهم يعني من
السفينه ساعود اليك لنقل الصوره مجددا
شكرا لك هاني لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات